[Music]
we know I think my opinion on grief can
be summed up in the words of Alan
Harrington from the immortal list when
he says any philosophy that accepts
death must itself be considered dead
it's questions meaningless its
consolations worn out I agree with him I
don't think there's any way to make
peace with death with mortality with the
human condition the fact that we can
ponder the infinite cosmos yet we're
ultimately food for worms
I find heart-wrenching Lee paralyzing
depressing sad beyond all measurable
limits the idea that everything and
everyone you love is going to be taken
away from you is unacceptable to me I
think it's just unacceptable
being okay with those terms imposed on
us by said universe you know if the
cosmos is comfortable with entropy
that's one thing it doesn't mean I have
to be comfortable with entropy in fact
I'm a member of the kingdom of life and
life is anti-entropic life moves towards
greater complexity an organization as
Kurzweil says more knowledge more
science more more more sprouting
possibilities and some people say that
maybe death is an evolutionary
meant to get rid of the old in order to
make room for the new that may have been
a stepping stone and necessary rehearsal
a way of spreading the diversity of
information sex and death genes mixed
together create something new kill off
the old shells but what if we're able to
create new rules what if we master
biotechnology we create software that
writes its own hardware we start to
change the rules of life we start
creating that diversity we start to be
the sort of mind at work here you know
it would be intelligent design at last
but the point being death would no
longer be necessary we could create a
world without loss without those
encounters with buried that may sound
like a sort of manic fantasy of sorts
but I think that's what mankind has
always done through his art is
articulate his desire to be eternal to
be infinite even by the way they're in a
mundo wrote nothing is real that is not
a Turner as while we write poetry and we
build cathedrals that try to create
transcendence as a topographical
statement that's why we eternal eyes
beautifu comments and make gorgeous
statues and write amazing songs we long
to eternal eyes ourselves we want to say
as Alain de Botton said we want to carve
our names we want to say I was here I
exist I felt something and I matter and
we matter and that's why death has
become an imposition on the human race
it is no longer acceptable
my words
[Music]